[موسيقى]
حديث اليوم كلمه
الرياده
الرياضه اهمتها
هي خلق الارض
صنع المستقبل اذا باوع البلدان الاخرى
الاشقاء العرب ايش سووا ببلدانهم الامارات
الانجازات الحققتها
السعوديه بناء نظره عشرين ثلاثين
قطر اللي
اضيفت البطوله العالم
المنشات اللي خلقتها
فخر
العراق
لازم يكون رائد ومتميز كما كان
زعاء حديد
مثال
للرياده العراقيه في العماره العالميه
حديد ليست مجرد معماريه عبقريه متميزه
ذا حديد استوعبت
تاريخ العراق
8000 سنه
وذا حديد ما توقفت عن الاستيعاب فقط وانما
زهاء حديد خلقت مكونات جديده ذات جينات
جديده متميزه ورائده
بهذا طورت العراق
وجلبتها الى الامام من
صغيره كانت دائما عندي احلام
وشنت دائما اكون في خيالي مدن مستقبليه
مدن مثاليه
ومن دخلت جامعه بغداد
قسم الهندسه المعماريه
بالثمانينات كانت ساعه حديد في بدايتها
وكانت كان اعمالها حلم تشبه احلامي
واهميتها بالنسبه الي كانت كبيره
لان قامت تسوي افكارها واقعيه
فاعطت حث
ودعم واسناد داخلي انه هذا الشيء ممكن
احققه
تركت العراق سنه 1991 ضمن ظروف صعبه
مستحيله
ودرست في احسن الجامعات العالميه وتفوقت
بين المتفوقين المعماريين
والطريق طويل
اشتغلت على نفسي وطورت امكانياتي
واشتغلت بكل مكان واشتغلت باصعب مدينه
اللي بيها تجمع كل الموهوبين والمبدعين
مدينه نيويورك
وتحقق الحلم
فتحت مكتبي 2010
وهذا كان اول من احلامي
في نفس الوقت
الي مبدئي بالعماره اللي هو مبدا مثالي بس
حقيقي وممكن يطبق
اني اؤمن بالابداع
والاستدامه والتكنولوجيا
وما اؤمن بها بطريقه اضافيه
وانما اؤمن بها بطريقه اسميها محيوكه
بالطريقه التفكير
يعني تخيل البنايه مو فقط
تحافظ على الطاقه وتستعملها بطريقه واعيه
وانما ممكن البنايه تكون مثل
لتوفير الاستدامه اللي هي مو بس بيئيه
وانما اقتصاديه واجتماعيه
هاي وحده من التاورات ناطحه سحاب اللي
تصميمها تصميم الواجهه معتمد على علاقته
باشعه الشمس حتى تخلق اقل ما يمكن من
منع الحراره من الدخول الى البنايه
مثل مسابقه
جوجل
هذا مثال الى ان كيف الواجهه هنا تعبر عن
محتويات المعرض فهذا به حاله جماليه حاله
رمزيه بس اكو حاله اخرى اللي هي محيوكه من
ضمن تصميم الواجهه الواجهه مصنوعه من
خلايا شمسيه هاي الخلايا الشمسيه تولد
الطاقه اللي تشغل المتحف وبالتالي تعطي
اشاره للمدينه ككل باهميه هذا الصرح
في قطر جامع قطر الرياضي اللي هو مستوحات
من فكره شجره السدره اللي الاغصان والجذور
تتسلق البنايه الاغصان والجذور نفسها اللي
تكون تكوين فكره البنايه مصنوعه من خلايا
شمسيه وبالتالي هاي البنايه تولد الطاقه
بنيه
هي الحقيقه مثل هياكل انشائيه هاي الهياكل
الانشائيه اكيد بها جماليه معينه بس بيها
تكنولوجيا عاليه وبيها استراتيجيه عميقه
التفكير كيف تحويل بنايه تكون مصدر مصدر
الرزق مصدر العيش لان هي البنايه نفسها هي
الممكن ان تعيش بها وتشتغل بها وفي نفس
الوقت هي تنتج الطعام اللي اللي تاكله
المجتمع اللي ياكله وكذلك ممكن تصدر طاقه
فتح المشاكل بيئيه مشاكل المياه مشاكل
الطاقه مدينه ليبرلاند اللي هي في اوروبا
عباره عن مدينه مثاليه
تجمع المهاجرين وبيها اسس وفرص للعمل اللي
مركزها الابداع والتكنولوجيا
والاستدامه اللي هي دائما اؤمن بها تكون
لازم اقتصاديه بيئيه واجتماعيه طبقات
المدينه
عباره عن كل خطوط المياه
الخطوط الكهرباء كلها تغذى من خلال
الطبقات اللي تنمو تحتها الطحالب اللي
بيها فائده
اعطاء الطاقه
جامع الخور في دبي
التفكير
في هذا المشروع ان شلون واحد يستعمل
التركنولوجيا بطريقه حديثه ومتقدمه بدون
استخدام اعمده وانما هي عباره عن قطع
انشائيه تتركب وتكون الهيكل وفيها بناء
ثلاثي الابعاد الطبع عن طريق ثلاثي
الابعاد هاي البنايه ممكن تحقق جوده عاليه
بوقت قصير جدا
وهذا الفضاء اللي هو مستوحات من فكره
المقرنصات الاسلاميه
مركز الالهام
كلها عباره عن طبع ثلاثي الابعاد
سنه 2020
انا عايشه كنت بدبي
وصار اكسبو 2020
واحده من البلدان طلبت من عندي اصمم لهم
جناح وصممت لهم الجناح بعدين فكرت قلت زين
العراق شلون وين جناح العراق رحت للسفاره
العراقيه بابو ظبي وقلت لهم
العراق وين جناحها قالوا لي ماكو ماكو
ميزانيه قلت لهم اني اصمم الجناح العراقي
رحله تصميم الجناح العراقي اخذت مني ثلاث
سنين رحله بها تضحيات كبيره بس اني
بالنسبه الي خلق
خلق الاهميه العراقي يكون بالجناح اهم من
اي شيء
رحله طويله بها كفاح وبيها تحديات هوايه
فكره التصميم جناح عراقي مبني على السليه
اللي هي رمز الوفره والخير في بلاد
الرافدين السليه تحمي نهر الدجله والفرات
وتمثل العراق من شماله الى جنوبه
وهو واحد من الاجنحه النادره اللي كانت
حققت ابداع بدون كلفه بسبب المحافظه على
البيئه لان الجناح اكثر يعتمد على التبريد
بالطريقه السلبيه
لهذا هو لا يستعمل اي طاقه
اليوم اللي كان
علم العراق يرفرف بين باقي الاعلام كان
احلى يوم بحياتي
نهايه الموضوع انه رياده كلش مهمه والعراق
لازم يكون في
هذا الدور انه يجلب الامل
ويخلق الانف للاجيال القادمه شكرا
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]